Hãy không vuyến tham tổ bị tư trụ tiền nước đã hội đam, khuôi kiến với các định đảo kết cao của xưa ra tham dự giữ dễ đàn khoa học công nghệ đổi mới sáng tạo.
Dép các hoang nghiệp tập bọn kinh tế và chi thức kêu bào.
Hãy bên tay hợp định đề tạng bứng chắc của khoa hiện đối tắc trí lực tòa diện,
nhất chỉ làm sâu sắc, hợp tắc tríng trị của phòng Anh Ninh, Anh Ninh Mạng,
đồng thời đưa khoa công nghệ đổi mới sáng tạo, và truyền đối sấu trà thành đục lực mới.
Hãy nước thông nhất mà giọc hợp tắc trong các liên bực trế lực như chi tội nghiên tạo,
bán dẫn khoang sản thiết yêu trên đổi sáng và đào tạo diện lực trên lực cao.
Nhân dịt này, hãy bên đả thông qua bát tuân bố chung và ký mởi bà văn kệ hợp tắc,
tổ quy thư trụ tiền nước của giữ lệ khánh thành nhà Việt Nam, chú sở mới đại xíu quan Việt Nam,
bà gập gớt tổng đồng người Việt tại O suy liá,
chứng tham đã thành công tốt đẹp tạo xung lực mới được quan đệ xong phương phát triển xong rọng và miền bương.